This is 99% Invisible. I am Roman Mars. It's a Saturday afternoon in Golden Gate Park, and a handful of kids are taking turns sending a little white stomper rocket into the grey San Francisco sky. It arcs up then sails back down to this small meadow at the northern edge of the park, bounded by shaggy evergreens. Yeah, so the rocket lands, the kids go apeshit, then they proceed to tear off after it, fully oblivious to the tall, thin man, watching from atop a nearby boulder. That's producer Chris Collins.
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。这是一个周六的下午，在金门公园，几个孩子轮流把一个小小的白色“踩踏火箭”发射到旧金山灰蒙蒙的天空中。火箭划出一道弧线，然后落回公园北缘的一片小草地上，四周环绕着蓬松的常青树。火箭落地了，孩子们兴奋得大喊大叫，然后一窝蜂地跑过去追赶它，完全没有注意到旁边一块巨石上坐着一位身材高瘦的男人。那是制片人克里斯·柯林斯。
The man is made of bronze, and this obscure little corner of the park is named for him. The Doughboy statue was unveiled here in the Doe Boy Meadow in 1930. He's a handsome young guy gazing out resolutely at the patch of earth that has borne his name for almost a century. I was just curious about one thing. So I walked up to a couple sitting near the Stomp Rocket kids. Hey, can I ask you guys a question? Yeah. Who is that guy? I actually don't know. Do you know who that is?
那个人是青铜做的，公园里这个不起眼的小角落就是以他的名字命名的。这座“面团男孩”（Doughboy）雕像于1930年在这里的“面团男孩草地”揭幕。他是一个英俊的年轻人，坚定地注视着这片以他的名字命名了近一个世纪的土地。我只是对一件事感到好奇。于是我走到坐在“踩踏火箭”孩子们附近的一对夫妇身边。嘿，能问你们一个问题吗？可以。那个人是谁？我其实不知道。你知道那是谁吗？
Who's what? That statue right behind you. Doughboy? Do you know what a Doughboy is? I just knew this was Doughboy Meadows, deductive reasoning. I'm a lucky guess. I present this high-level exchange because it illustrates something about our world.
谁是什么？你身后那座雕像。面团男孩？你知道什么是面团男孩吗？我只知道这里是面团男孩草地，这是演绎推理。我只是瞎猜的。我提出这段高水平的对话，是因为它说明了我们世界的一些情况。
Specifically the bronze and granite corner of our world, where we memorialize the losses most important to us as a civilization. The Doe Boy Meadow commemorates 39 San Franciscans who were killed in World War I. 16 more were killed in World War II, and their names were added to the plaque under the statue. Dillboys are what they used to call infantrymen back in the day, a fact that nobody Chris interviewed on the meadow that morning seemed to know,
具体来说，是我们世界中青铜和花岗岩的角落，我们在那里纪念作为文明对我们最重要的损失。“面团男孩草地”纪念了39名在第一次世界大战中阵亡的旧金山人。又有16人在第二次世界大战中阵亡，他们的名字被加到了雕像下的牌匾上。“面团男孩”是过去人们对步兵的称呼，那天早上克里斯在草地上采访的每个人似乎都不知道这个事实，
or care about, which, you know, fine. But it raises questions in your mind about the purpose of memorials. Or at least it does if, like me, you've spent the last year walking up to every memorial you see and wondering what they say about us and wondering what they even do. So that's partly why I wandered over to the Doughboy Meadow that Saturday. But I have to admit something to you, which is that this story is not about Doughboys. In fact, this whole scene in the dough boy meadow has allowed me to put off mentioning something
或者根本不在乎，这也没什么。但这让你对纪念碑的目的产生了疑问。至少如果你像我一样，过去一年里走近你看到的每一座纪念碑，想知道它们在诉说着我们什么，甚至想知道它们到底有什么用，你就会有这种疑问。所以，这就是我那个周六溜达到面团男孩草地的部分原因。但我必须向你承认一件事，那就是这个故事并不是关于面团男孩的。事实上，面团男孩草地的整个场景让我推迟了提及某件事，
that I fear will make you yank out your earbuds the moment I bring it up. But here goes. This is actually a story about COVID. More specifically, it's about a group of people fighting to create a memorial for a devastating disease that many of us just don't want to talk about or think about anymore.
我担心一旦我提出来，你就会拔掉耳机。但还是说了吧。这其实是一个关于新冠的故事。更具体地说，它是关于一群人努力为一种毁灭性的疾病建立纪念碑，而我们许多人只是不想再谈论或思考这种疾病了。
He was tall and handsome. He was a very handsome guy. I don't know what that means to me that he's sad. That's Kristen Urquiza talking about her dad. Lately, she's been having this recurring dream about him. He's wearing his quintessential early 90s gear, which includes aviators, you know, off-brand Ray-Bans, a polo shirt, and these like tiny little McGregor shorts that are like made out of vinyl or something really interesting
他很高大英俊。他是个非常英俊的人。我不知道他悲伤对我意味着什么。那是克里斯汀·乌尔基扎在谈论她的父亲。最近，她一直在做关于他的重复梦。他穿着典型的90年代初的装备，包括飞行员墨镜，你知道的，非名牌的雷朋，一件Polo衫，还有那些像是由乙烯基或其他非常有趣的东西制成的超短麦格雷戈短裤，
and he's got like the knee-high socks. So he's just in this gazebo sort of like beckoning me to come and be with him. Kristen grew up with her dad and mom in Phoenix. They lived in a neighborhood called Maryville, a working class community that's largely immigrant and mostly Latino. And that's where Kristen's parents were still living in 2020, when the world first heard the word coronavirus. At first the family was on the same page about this mysterious new disease.
还有他穿着及膝袜。所以他就在凉亭里，好像在招手让我过去和他在一起。克里斯汀和她的父母在菲尼克斯长大。他们住在一个叫玛丽维尔的社区，这是一个主要是移民和拉丁裔的工人阶级社区。2020年，当世界第一次听到“冠状病毒”这个词时，克里斯汀的父母仍然住在那里。起初，全家人对这种神秘的新疾病看法一致。
And that page was basically, this is terrifying. Jesus Christ, stay home. And then Trump decided to visit Arizona on May 5th. And I think that was a political move to go and declare that we were on the right path. Then the governor of Arizona went on a PR spree across the state saying that it was safe to go about normal. And that's when my relationship, when my conversations, when everything with my dad started to change. A couple things about her dad, Mark or Keeza. One, he was a Fox News watching
那看法基本上就是：这太可怕了。天哪，待在家里。然后特朗普决定在5月5日访问亚利桑那州。我认为那是一个政治举动，去宣布我们走在正确的道路上。然后亚利桑那州州长在全州进行了一场公关活动，说正常生活是安全的。就在那时，我和我父亲的关系，我们的谈话，一切都开始改变了。关于她父亲马克·乌尔基扎的几件事。第一，他是一个看福克斯新闻、热爱美国的家伙。如果他选出的人说新冠对健康人来说是可控的，他就相信。第二，这家伙喜欢聚会。他快乐、甜美、热情，嗓门很大。如果有人在房间的角落里，他会确保他们感到自己是其中的一部分。某某的生日，或者一场重要的纳斯卡比赛，或者任何值得庆祝的场合，我爸爸就是那种热衷于体验快乐的人。所以当一位朋友在亚利桑那州的居家令解除后不久举办生日卡拉OK派对时，马克毫不犹豫地去了。
America-loving guy. If the guys he elected said COVID was under control for healthy people, he believed it. Two, dude loved a party. He was happy and sweet and exuberant with this big voice. And if anyone was at the edge of the room, he made sure they felt part of things. So-and-so's birthday or an important NASCAR race or any occasion in which to celebrate, like my dad was such a booster for experiencing joy. So Mark didn't hesitate when a friend through a birthday karaoke party not long after Arizona's stay at home orders were lifted.
几周内，马克·乌尔基扎就住进了医院。虽然他身体状况良好，但病情恶化了。他被转入重症监护室，然后独自一人被戴上了呼吸机。6月30日，克里斯汀正从她位于旧金山的家中开车前往菲尼克斯，这时她得知他快不行了。在高速公路旁的一个加油站，她和父亲通了话，医院的一名护士把手机举到他的耳边。不久之后他就去世了。护士握着他的手。
Within a few weeks, Mark or Kiza was in the hospital. And though he was otherwise healthy, his condition worsened. He got moved to the ICU, and then, all alone, he was put on a ventilator. Kristen was driving to Phoenix from her home in San Francisco on June 30th, when she learned he was slipping away. At a gas station on the side of the highway, she spoke to her father as a nurse at the hospital held up a phone to his ear. He died soon after that. The nurse held his hand.
马克曾是高中400米短跑州冠军和越野跑运动员。马克以其富有感染力的活力、坚强的意志和固执而闻名。这是克里斯汀为她父亲写的讣告，它既可爱又令人心碎，然后话锋一转。马克，像许多其他人一样，本不应该死于新冠肺炎。他的死是由于那些继续危及棕色人种健康的政客们的粗心大意，
Mark was a high school 400 meter dash state champion and cross country runner. Mark was known for his infectious energy, strong will, and yes, stubbornness. This is the obituary Kristen wrote for her father, it's lovely and heartbreaking, and then it takes a turn. Mark, like so many others, should not have died from COVID-19. His death is due to the carelessness of the politicians who continue to jeopardize the health of brown bodies,
由于明显的领导力缺失，拒绝承认这场危机的严重性，以及无法且不愿就如何最大限度地降低风险给出明确和果断的指导。克里斯汀不仅悲痛欲绝，而且愤怒至极。那篇讣告做了一件相当了不起的事情。它邀请任何有亲人受新冠折磨或死于新冠的人，加入她在亚利桑那州议会大厦外创建的一个祭坛。2020年7月，还没有人真正表达过这种悲伤和愤怒。
through a clear lack of leadership, refusal to acknowledge the severity of this crisis, and inability and unwillingness to give clear and decisive direction on how to minimize risk. Kristen wasn't just beside herself with grief. She was furious. And the obituary did something kind of remarkable. It invited anyone with loved ones suffering from COVID, or having died from COVID, to join an altar she was creating outside the Arizona State Capitol. In July of 2020, nobody had really articulated this kind of sadness and anger yet.
讣告在互联网上炸开了锅。很快，州长就被问及马克的死。到了8月，克里斯汀正在通过Zoom在民主党全国代表大会上发言。我爸爸是一个健康的65岁老人。他唯一的既往症就是信任唐纳德·特朗普，为此他付出了生命的代价。好吧，这听起来像是要演变成一场反特朗普的演说。有一段时间，克里斯汀的生活基本上就是一场反特朗普的演说。但当这一切发生时，背景中还有别的事情在发生。
The obit exploded across the internet. Soon, the governor was being asked about Mark's death. By August, Kristen was speaking by Zoom at the Democratic National Convention. My dad was a healthy 65-year-old. His only preexisting condition was trusting Donald Trump, and for that he paid with his life. Okay, this sounds like it's winding up into an anti-Trump harangue. For a minute, Kristen's life was basically an anti-Trump harangue. But as that was going on, something else was happening in the background.
普通人开始联系克里斯汀。在这个直言不讳的39岁非营利组织工作者身上，他们看到了一个理解这个国家正在发生什么的人。几十个，然后几百个，最终成千上万的陌生人开始与她分享他们的悲伤。我不认为世界上有任何人比我谈论过更多失去亲人的人。顺便说一句，这是我从许多人那里听到的关于克里斯汀的话。她听到的越多，她的观点就开始演变。
Ordinary people started reaching out to Kristen. In this plain-spoken 39-year-old non-profit worker, they saw someone who grasped what was really happening in this country. Dozens and then hundreds and eventually thousands of strangers began to share their grief with her. I don't think there's anybody in the entire world who's talked to as many folks who've lost a loved one to COVID than me. That's something I've heard from a number of people about Kristen, incidentally. And the more people she heard from, the more her view began to evolve.
当时新冠占据了头条新闻。这是每个人都在谈论的话题。然而，我们仍然没有真正面对那种纯粹的、可怕的损失。它正在磨损着世界。所有这些死亡显然是我们对新冠恐惧的核心，但矛盾的是，我们还没有创造一个空间或地方来纪念那些真正死去的人。克里斯汀觉得，除非我们这样做，
COVID was dominating the headlines at the time. It was all anyone talked about. And yet, we still weren't really reckoning with the amount of sheer, horrific loss. It was grinding into the world. All this death was obviously central to our fears about COVID, but paradoxically, we hadn't created a space or a place to honor the actual people who were dying. Kristen felt like until we did,
否则这个国家永远不会真正治愈，这也意味着它不会学会在下一次做得更好。克里斯汀沉浸在悲伤中，但有一件事突然变得清晰起来。有人需要为子孙后代记录下这场灾难。当然，无数更小、更本地化的纪念碑已经涌现，其中许多非常出色。但克里斯汀想要一些全国性和历史性的东西，一个为整个国家建立的永久性新冠纪念碑。它需要像
the country was never really going to heal, which also meant it wasn't going to learn to do better the next time. Kristen was lost in sadness, but one thing felt suddenly clear. Someone needed to mark this catastrophe for generations to come. Countless smaller and more local memorials have sprung up, of course, many of them phenomenal. But Kristin wanted something national and historic in scope, A permanent COVID memorial for the whole country. It needed to be as
大流行本身一样宏大，足够灵活以适应一种仍在发展的疾病，足够批判以认识到它如何加剧了国内的其他社会危机，并且足够复杂以某种方式反映我们最终对大流行所拥有的所有截然不同的感受。于是她决定给美国纪念部打电话，他们立刻着手创建一个永久且非常深思熟虑的全国性新冠纪念碑。但问题是，根本没有纪念部。当修建一条高速公路时，有一个清晰且一致的流程。公共纪念碑则不然。当修建一条高速公路时，有一个清晰且一致的流程。公共纪念碑则不然。从越战纪念墙到国家和平与正义纪念碑，
big as the pandemic itself, and flexible enough to accommodate a still unfolding disease, and critical enough to recognize how it exacerbated other societal crises in the country, and sophisticated enough to somehow reflect all of the wildly different feelings we'd eventually have about the pandemic. So she decided to call the United States Department of Memorialization, and they got right to work creating a permanent and very thoughtful national memorial to the COVID pandemic. Except there is no Department of Memorialization. When, say, a highway gets made, there's a clear and consistent process for doing so. Not so public memorials. When, say, a highway gets made, there's a clear and consistent process for doing so. Not so public memorials. From the Vietnam Wall to the National Memorial
情况总是不同。有时是一群关心此事的公民聚在一起促成此事。有时是一个非营利组织或基金会推动此事。通常会有很多激进主义和关于设计、选址、它应该讲述关于发生了什么以及受影响者是谁的故事的激烈讨论。理想情况下，还有另一整套关于谁的观点被反映、谁的观点被扭曲，以及什么未言明的议程被嵌入项目中的讨论。当你讨论一座纪念碑或构思一座纪念碑时，有时最富有成效的部分就是讨论本身。
for Peace and Justice, it's always different. Sometimes a handful of concerned citizens get together and make it happen. Sometimes a nonprofit pushes for it or a foundation. There's usually a lot of activism and a lot of fraught conversations about design, location, the story it should tell about what happened and who it affected. And ideally, there's a whole nother set of conversations about whose perspectives are being reflected and whose are being distorted and what unspoken agendas are embedding themselves in the project. When you discuss a memorial or when you conceive a memorial, sometimes the most productive part of it is the discussion itself.
这是玛丽安·赫希，一位哥伦比亚大学教授，在记忆研究和我们如何记忆文化创伤方面做了大量工作。因为那是我们试图作为一个社区或一组社区来弄清楚发生了什么以及我们想要如何记忆它，但也包括我们想要如何为未来记忆它的地方。这个国家有超过48,000座纪念碑和纪念物。正如我们近年来所了解到的，这很可能意味着关于它们应该和不应该纪念什么的48,000场争论。嗯，现在是讨论这个问题的有趣时刻，
This is Marianne Hirsch, a Columbia professor who does a lot of work in memory studies and how we remember cultural trauma. Because that is where we try to figure out as a community or as a set of communities what happened and how we want to remember it, but also how we want to remember it for the future. They're more than 48,000 monuments and memorials in this country. And as we've all learned in recent years, that can very well mean 48,000 arguments about what they should and shouldn't be commemorating. Well, it's an interesting time to discuss this question
因为我们正处于这个国家的记忆战争之中，对吧？我们的纪念碑和纪念物已经成为争论的场所，有些甚至在我们说话的时候就被拆除了。如何记忆。记忆什么。如何哀悼。如何准确地哀悼。
because we're in the midst of memory wars in this country, right? Our monuments and memorials have become sites of contestation, and some of them are being dismantled even as we speak. How to remember. What to remember. How to grieve. How to grieve accurately.
如果此时你仍然感到震惊，认为克里斯汀·乌尔基扎，一个在旧金山公寓里工作的普通人，必须处理所有这些巨大的历史考量。是的，排队吧。因为当克里斯汀开始四处打听时，她意识到她就是那个人。在政府或个人层面，没有其他人致力于她所设想的规模的新冠纪念碑。对于这场袭击美国的最致命疾病的悲剧，没有集中的公共承诺来纪念它。
If at this point you're still struck that Kristen Orkiza, a regular person working out of her apartment in San Francisco, must wade through all these massive historic considerations. Yeah, take a number. Because as Kristen began asking around, she realized that she was it. There was no one else at the government or individual level working on a COVID memorial of the magnitude she imagined. There is no concentrated public commitment to commemorating the tragedy of the deadliest disease that's hit the US.
就像，我甚至无法理解这一点。但她确实理解了。到2020年7月，也就是国家关闭仅四个月后，克里斯汀和她的伴侣克里斯汀·基夫斯就发起了一个全国性的非营利组织。它叫“被新冠标记”（Marked by COVID）。很快就有了Facebook页面和网站，
Like, I can't even wrap my head around that. But she also did wrap her head around it. And by July of 2020, just four months after the country shut down, Kristen and her partner, Christine Keeves, had launched a national nonprofit. It was called Marked by COVID. Soon there was a Facebook page and a website
以及与公职人员的接触，并与他们能找到的每个人进行组织工作。在厨房的餐桌上，他们与成百上千名丧亲者通信。他们帮助他们撰写讣告，帮助他们发布这些讣告，并筹集资金支付这些讣告。他们给市长打电话，与世界各地的记者交谈。当有空闲时间时，他们看得更远。两个大想法冒了出来。
and outreach to public officials and organizing efforts with everyone they could find. At their kitchen table, they corresponded with hundreds and then thousands of bereaved people. They helped them write obituaries and helped them place those obituaries and raise money to pay for those obituaries. They called mayors and talked with reporters all over the world. And when there was a free moment, they looked even further down the road. Two big ideas bubbled up.
第一，创建一个联邦认可的新冠纪念日，即三月的第一个星期一；第二，建立一个永久性的国家新冠纪念碑。很快他们就开始起草政策声明并与国会议员会面，但出现了一种奇怪的动态。“被新冠标记”正在成为全国最大、组织最严密的纪念活动。但与此同时，他们在这个项目中也是弱势群体。
One, to create a federally recognized COVID Memorial Day, the first Monday in March, and two, to establish a permanent national COVID Memorial. Soon they were drafting a policy statement and meeting with Congress members, but a weird dynamic emerged. Marked by COVID was becoming the biggest, most organized memorialization effort in the country. But at the same time, they were also the underdog in this project.
正如克里斯汀有一天喝茶时向我解释的那样，像他们这样的草根行动在纪念活动的世界里处于结构性劣势。例如，梅隆基金会，他们有一个令人难以置信的纪念碑项目。他们只接受邀请。那么，谁是有资格被像梅隆基金会这样真正精英的机构邀请的人呢？那将是学者，是已经获得资助的人，或者是他们扩展网络内的人。
As Kristin explained to me over tea one day, a grassroots operation like theirs is at a structural disadvantage in the world of memorialization. So for example, the Mellon Foundation, they have an incredible monuments program. They are by invitation only. So who are the folks that are in positions to be able to be by invitation only to a really elite institution like the Mellon Foundation? It's going to be folks who are academics, it's going to be people who have already received funding or people within their extended networks.
这种事让克里斯汀感到恼火，但并没有让她灰心。部分原因是，作为一个人的选择菜单里根本没有“放弃”这一项。但这也是更宏大的事情。对于这座纪念碑，“被新冠标记”的愿景正在增长。它变得如此巨大，以至于任何障碍相比之下都显得微不足道。这个想法不仅仅是在这场难以想象的巨大灾难面前提供慰藉。他们想要掌握社会如何集体记忆这场大流行的主导权。我们有纪念各种共享经历的纪念碑。
This kind of thing, it irked Kristen, but it didn't discourage her. Partly, that's just not on her drop-down menu of options as a person. But it's also something bigger. Marked by COVID's vision for this memorial was growing. It was becoming so huge that any obstacle seemed tiny by comparison. The idea wasn't just to offer solace in the face of this unimaginably vast catastrophe. They wanted to take the reins of how society collectively remembers the pandemic altogether. We have memorials to commemorate a huge variety of shared experiences.
我们纪念战争、地震、龙卷风、洪水、饥荒和骚乱。有纪念失踪渔民、失踪宇航员，甚至失踪的林纳德·斯金纳德乐队成员的纪念碑。没有一场内战的小规模冲突没有被刻在某处的大理石上。但如果你打算建造其中一座纪念碑，它应该说什么，应该怎么说？
We memorialize wars, earthquakes, tornadoes, floods, famines, and riots. There are memorials to lost fishermen, lost astronauts, even lost members of Leonard Skinnerd. There isn't a civil war skirmish that hasn't been carved into marble somewhere. But if you're setting out to make one of those memorials, what should it say, and how should it say it?
这是“被新冠标记”在踏上征程时面临的核心问题。碰巧，克里斯汀有一位大学老友萨拉·辛克，她成为了一名文学教授，专注于记忆和创伤。这是一个以思考人们如何记忆和理解重大可怕事件为生的人。
That was the central issue facing Mark by COVID as they set out on their quest. As it happened, Kristen had an old friend from college, Sarah Sink, who'd become a literature professor with a focus on memory and trauma. This is a person who makes a living thinking about how people remember and make sense of big horrible events.
她也认同克里斯汀的信念，即这个可怕的事件需要一种全新的方法。所以当克里斯汀意识到她将成为纪念部时，她请萨拉帮忙。绕过街区。你看到了吗？是的。
She also shared Kristen's conviction that this horrible event needed a new approach altogether. So when Kristen realized she was going to be the department of memorialization, she asked Sarah to pitch in. Go around the block. You saw it? Yeah.
我能看到其中一根横梁。在一个寒冷的周三早上，我和萨拉开车去加利福尼亚州的纳帕，去看看一个更近期的纪念碑。我想亲眼看看她那解读牌匾的大脑是如何工作的。我们下车走过星巴克，来到主街旁一个类似小公园的地方。好了，我们在这里看什么？
I can see one of the beams. On a nippy Wednesday morning, I drive up to Napa, California with Sarah to check out a more recent memorial. I wanna see firsthand how her plaque reading brain works. We get out of the car and walk past the Starbucks to a small park-like area just off Main Street. All right, what are we looking at here?
嗯，我们正在看，让我们看看，从这个角度，我看到五块垂直排列的钢片，看起来有四块玻璃板。在我们上方隐约可见的是我猜可以算作普通公共艺术的东西，除了你立刻就知道那些钢梁是什么，它们来自哪里。我们正站在纳帕9-11纪念花园。我认为非常有趣的一点是，它们垂直排列的方式，
Well, we are looking at, let's see, from this angle, I see five different pieces of steel vertically aligned, and it looks like there are four panes of glass. Looming above us is what I suppose could pass for generic public art, except you just know instantly what those steel beams are, where they came from. We're standing in the Napa 9-11 Memorial Garden. One thing I think is really interesting is that the way they vertically align them,
让你处于一种必须伸长脖子向上看的姿势。许多9-11纪念碑都这样做。它们让你处于那天目击者的位置。在接下来的半小时左右，我上了一堂纪念活动的速成课。微妙的审美或措辞决定如何能改变你对一个事件的看法，这反过来又会影响更大的事情。
it puts you in a position of like craning your neck upwards to look. And a lot of the 9-11 memorials do this. They put you in the position of like a witness on the day. For the next half hour or so, I get a crash course in commemoration. The way subtle aesthetic or wording decisions can tip the way you think about an event, which in turn can tip bigger things.
这个国家如何或如何不从那个事件中治愈，或者它如何继续对那个事件做出反应。有一次，萨拉在纪念碑上看到了一段铭文。它被描述为一个反思的地方，旨在激励我们继续表达那天世界所经历的勇气、关怀和同情。那个词，“我们的世界”，真的让我很触动，因为那绝对不包括这次袭击的实施者或任何同情他们的人。所以有一种……这就是如果你要创建自己的纪念碑时所需要的细读思维。因为悲伤、记忆、纪念，这些都是基本且直观的概念，直到你哪怕花一点点时间去思考它们。
How the country does or doesn't heal from that event, or how it goes on to respond to that event. At one point, Sarah comes across an inscription on the memorial. And it's described as a place of reflection meant to inspire us to continue to express this courage, caring and compassion, or world experience that day. That word, our world, really pops out to me because that's definitely not including the perpetuators of this attack or anyone who sympathizes with them. And so there's kind of a- This is the close reading mind that you want if you're going to create a memorial of your own. Because grief, memory, commemoration, these are basic and straightforward concepts only until you give them even a moment's thought.
你到底想让后代记住什么？假设你想纪念9月11日。第一步是决定你到底想让后代记住什么。那天遇难的2,977人？是的，当然。但随后你必须决定你到底想记住关于他们的什么。那9-11的更广泛意义呢？那不应该成为我们反思的一部分吗？
What exactly do you want future generations to remember? Let's say you want to memorialize September 11th. Step one is deciding what exactly you want future generations to remember. The 2,977 people who were killed that day? Yes, of course. But then you have to decide what you want to remember about them exactly. And what about the broader significance of 9-11? Shouldn't that be part of what we reflect on?
更广泛的意义对谁而言？你如何在不陷入支持由此产生的对外政策的情况下捕捉那天的恐怖？顺便问一下，我们到底应该记住事情多久？我们应该为巴比伦起义建立纪念碑吗？根据我的研究，那些也是真实的人。总之，回到纳帕，萨拉和我讨论了编码在这个和其他9-11
And broader significance for whom? And how do you capture the horror of that day without, say, slipping into support for the foreign of that day without, say, slipping into support for the foreign policy that grew out of it? And by the way, how long are we supposed to remember things in the first place? Should we have memorials to the Babylonian revolt? Those were real people too, according to my research. Anyway, back in Napa, Sarah and I discussed the messaging coded into this and other 9-11
纪念碑中的信息。一个信息当然是“永不忘记”。“永不忘记”的讽刺之处在于，我们从未忘记的实际上是一个精心制作的叙事，无论是无意识还是有意识的，对吧？但这是一个关于被外部力量攻击的叙事，在某种程度上这是一种经典的复仇叙事。纪念碑倾向于纪念清晰且戏剧性的事件，甚至可能有点电影化。但对于新冠，没有英雄般的战斗。没有大楼倒塌。没有海滩被强攻。可怕的事情悄无声息地发生在重症监护室和卧室里，没有摄像机在拍摄，
memorials. One message, of course, is never forget. The irony of never forget is that what we were never forgetting was actually a carefully crafted narrative, unconsciously or consciously, right? But a narrative about being attacked by external forces, and it was kind of a classic revenge narrative in a way. Memorials tend to commemorate events that are clear and dramatic, maybe even a little cinematic. But with COVID, there was no heroic battle. No towers came down. No beach was stormed. The awfulness happened quietly in ICUs and in bedrooms where no cameras were rolling,
没有形成灼热的集体视觉效果。换句话说，除了其他一切之外，这场大流行在叙事上是不方便的。新冠三年了，我们对于我们经历了什么样的故事没有共识，因为实际上，这是一个关于许多事情的故事，包括韧性、恐惧、孤立，以及失去的工作和时间。这也是一个关于我们制度脆弱性的故事，关于大流行和乔治·弗洛伊德事件如何交织在一起，以及关于对我们孩子长期影响的故事。鉴于所有这些，我问萨拉她希望新冠纪念碑的核心叙事是什么。我不认为我希望它是什么很重要。我认为
where no searing collective visuals formed. In other words, on top of everything else, the pandemic has been narratively inconvenient. Three years into COVID, we have no consensus around what kind of story we got routed through, because really, it's a story of many things, including resilience, fear, isolation, and lost jobs and time. It's also a story about the fragility of our institutions and the way the pandemic and George Floyd braided together, and about the long-term impact on our kids. Given all of that, I asked Sarah what she wants the COVID Memorial's central narrative to be. I don't think it matters what I want it to be. I think the what she wants the COVID Memorial central narrative to be.
我不认为我希望它是什么很重要。我认为整个项目的目的就是说，这些叙事不应该由像我这样的人来塑造。它们应该由受影响最直接的人来塑造。从一开始，这个想法就是“被新冠标记”精神的核心。
I don't think it matters what I want it to be. I think the whole purpose of the project is to say that these narratives should not be shaped by people like me. They should be shaped by the people who are the most directly impacted. From the beginning, this idea was central to the marked by COVID ethos.
克里斯汀和所有参与其中的人都希望他们的纪念项目是民主的，而不是自上而下的。他们希望它包括受疾病打击最严重的人的声音，而不仅仅是最不方便的人。你已经可以感觉到某种大流行记忆在某些圈子里获得了流行。我们变得有点疯狂的方式。我们如何错过见朋友，我们如何不得不洗杂货一段时间。我们当时在集思广益，我们当时想，这不能作为我们都找不到
Kristen and everyone else involved wanted their remembrance project to be democratic, not top-down. They wanted it to include the voices most devastated by the disease, not just the most inconvenienced. Already you can sense a certain strain of pandemic memory gaining currency in certain circles. The ways we went kind of stir crazy. How we missed seeing our friends, how we had to wash our groceries for a while. We were brainstorming about this and we were like, this cannot be committed to national memory as the time that we all couldn't find
该死的酵母的时代被载入国家记忆。她后来告诉我，这不能成为一个酸面包纪念碑。这不能成为一个酸面包纪念碑。休息之后，克里斯汀和她在“被新冠标记”的团队完善了他们对新冠纪念碑的愿景，并在建造它的旅程中面临了一些巨大的障碍。到2021年秋天，“被新冠标记”社区已经发展到数千人。他们举行了无数次焦点小组会议，开始为纪念碑提出想法。最初，人们对像华盛顿特区玛雅·林设计的越战老兵纪念碑那样的东西感到兴奋。但一位政府官员计算出，考虑到有多少人死于
f***ing yeast. She told me later, this can't be a sourdough memorial. This can't be a sourdough memorial. After the break, Kristen and her team at Marked by COVID refined their vision for a COVID memorial and faced some huge obstacles in their journey to build it. By the fall of 2021, the marked by COVID community had grown into the thousands. They'd held countless focus groups to begin surfacing ideas for a memorial. Initially, people were excited about something like Maya Lin's Vietnam Veterans Memorial in DC. But a government official calculated that that given how many people had died
新冠，它必须绕国家广场环绕52圈。所以那个方案被否决了。庄严地刻在石头上的名字是不够的。但从其他对话中，一些事情变得清晰起来。首先，“被新冠标记”想要创建一个真正以哀悼者声音为中心的纪念碑。我们学到的是，这种对损失的确认是让人们继续前进的重要部分，包括我自己。这很重要。如果你看看其他危机，总有一个我们聚在一起反思的时刻。据估计，每有一个人死于新冠，就有九到十个严重丧亲的人留下来。许多遭受这种损失的人从未参加过葬礼，甚至没能对他们的父亲、母亲、配偶或孩子说
of COVID, it would have to wrap around the National Mall 52 times. So that was out. Names somberly carved into stone weren't going to cut it. But from other conversations, a number of things had become clear. For one, Mark by COVID wanted to create a memorial that actually centered the voices of the grieving. What we've learned is that that validation of loss is such an essential piece of keeping people going, myself included. That matters. And if you look at other crises, there is always a moment that we come together to reflect. It's been estimated that for every person lost to COVID, nine or ten severely bereaved individuals are left in their wake. So many of the people suffering that loss never got to attend a funeral or even say
一声正式的再见。所以社区的首要要求之一是，这个纪念碑必须是一个每个人都能亲自访问的地方。而且需要有关于那些亲人的面孔和个性化的语言。但即使在这个自选群体中，也很难找到一个对每个人都有效的东西，
a proper goodbye to their fathers, mothers, spouses, or children. So one of the top requests from the community was that this memorial be a place that everyone could visit in person. And there needed to be faces and personalized language about those loved ones. But even within this self-selected group, it wasn't easy to find something that worked for everyone,
更不用说更大的国家了。我的意思是，我不反对做一个新冠纪念碑。你想做一个新冠纪念碑，没问题。那是杰伊·布洛克，2022年新墨西哥州共和党州长候选人，现在是桑多瓦尔县专员。但为什么我们不谈论这里正在发生的所有不同问题的纪念碑，你知道，
to say nothing of the larger country. I mean, I don't have a problem doing a COVID memorial. You want to do a COVID memorial, fine. That's Jay Block, Republican gubernatorial candidate for New Mexico in 2022, and now Sandoval County Commissioner. But why aren't we talking about all the memorials to the different issues going on here with, you know,
这里街头发生的高犯罪率杀人事件，以及我们年轻人死于毒品的问题。实际上，布洛克确实对做一个新冠纪念碑有意见。2022年底，一些“被新冠标记”的成员在新墨西哥州开始与当地官员合作，在阿尔伯克基附近的土地上创建一个州级版本的纪念碑。当项目进行投票时，布洛克投了反对票。他不喜欢它的信息。所以我问他认为新冠纪念碑应该说什么。我很抱歉我强迫你接种了一种不能保护你免受新冠感染，也不能
high crime people getting killed in the streets here and our young people dying of drugs. And actually, Block did have a problem doing a COVID memorial. In late 2022, some marked by COVID members in New Mexico began working with local officials to create a state-level version of their memorial on land near Albuquerque. When the project went up for a vote, Block voted against it. He didn't like its message. So I asked what he thinks a COVID Memorial should say. I'm sorry that I forced you to get a vaccine that didn't protect you from COVID and didn't
防止你传播新冠，或者让你失去了工作。我很抱歉疫苗导致了你的心脏问题。我很抱歉我关闭了你的学校，也给你的孩子造成了这么多问题。这就是我想要的。这需要大量的雕琢。这需要大量的雕琢。每有一个杰伊·布洛克，就有8000万个其他的杰伊·布洛克。就在8月份，三分之一的美国人相信那个极其不真实的说法，即新冠疫苗导致了数千名健康人的猝死。这就是事情变得更加复杂的地方，
prevent you from spreading COVID or you lost your job. I'm sorry the vaccine caused heart issues in you. I'm sorry I shut your schools down and caused your children so many issues as well. That's what I would like. It's gonna take a lot of chiseling. It's gonna be a lot of chiseling. For every J block, there are 80 million other J blocks. As recently as August, a third of all Americans believe the screamingly untrue claim that the COVID vaccines caused thousands of sudden deaths and otherwise healthy people. And this is where things get even more complex,
因为如果“被新冠标记”希望纪念大流行对我们意味着什么，一个非常核心的方面不能被忽视。新冠是如何让我们陷入完全无法就基本事实达成一致的境地的。这恰好也是纪念碑的一个问题。因为国家纪念碑最终归结为对事件意义的国家共识。
because if marked by COVID hopes to memorialize what the pandemic meant for us, one very central aspect of it can't be overlooked. How COVID plunged us into a total inability to agree on basic facts. Which also happens to be a problem for a memorial. Because a national memorial ultimately boils down to a national agreement about the meaning of an event.
在三月的那一天，“被新冠标记”希望它能成为一个全国性的新冠纪念日。我去了旧金山市中心的韦斯特菲尔德购物中心。我花了一天时间问普通人他们对这个节日的看法，这变成了普遍询问关于新冠的问题，因为根本没人听说过这个节日。我们最好还是继续前进，所以我认为它不值得一个纪念日。是的。我有点受够了，你知道，我希望我们能找到一个解决方案，不再需要戴口罩，因为我知道它肯定影响了人们的自尊心之类的。
On the day in March that marked by COVID, hopes will become a national COVID Memorial Day. I take myself to the mall, the Westfield Mall in downtown San Francisco. I spend the day asking regular people what they think about this holiday, which turns into just generally asking about COVID since nobody has even heard of this holiday. We have down at best to move on, So I don't believe it warrants a memorial day. Yeah. I'm kind of over it, you know, like I hope like we can like find a solution to like no longer have to wear a mask because I know it's definitely like affecting people's like self-esteem and everything.
圣经中预言了会发生这种情况，因为它提到了瘟疫，而那正是新冠。从所有这些中，应该在这里留下关于新冠肺炎的什么文明记忆？在这样的日子里，我发现自己怀疑连贯性是否甚至是一种可能性。与此同时，围绕新冠的所有分裂和尖刻，它不仅仅阻碍了关于
It was prophesied in the Bible that this was going to happen because it mentions pestilences and that's what COVID was. What civilizational memory of the COVID-19 pandemic is supposed to go here from all that? On days like this, I find myself doubting that coherence is even a possibility. And in the meantime, all the divisiveness and vitriol around COVID, it doesn't just stymie conversations
纪念碑本身的对话。它相当于数百万丧亲者遭受的腐蚀性侮辱。克里斯汀本人不得不阅读无数条信息，告诉她她父亲死于新冠本质上是不真实的。学者们称之为“被剥夺的悲伤”。当你哀悼某件事，而越来越多的人说那根本不是一回事时，就会发生这种情况。在克里斯汀的案例中，她有足够的斗志继续前进。但她需要组织的许多人已经厌倦了战斗。不断地为你的亲人为什么去世以及为什么这很重要进行辩护是非常令人沮丧的。而且，你知道，这有助于泄气。
about the memorial itself. It amounts to a corrosive FU from millions of bereaved people. Kristen herself had to read countless messages telling her her father's death by COVID was essentially not real. Scholars call this disenfranchised grief. It's when you're mourning something that more and more people are saying is not really a thing. In Kristen's case, she's got enough fight in her to press on. But many of the people she needs to organize are tired of fighting. It is very demoralizing to constantly have to be defending why your loved one died and why it matters. And that, you know, helps to take the wind out of the sails.
换句话说，那种煤气灯效应不仅仅是可怕的。它削弱了人们分享故事的意愿。但是，克里斯汀很快指出，民主党人也阻挠了这个项目，尽管是以不同的方式。早在2021年，她飞往华盛顿特区会见拜登总统的一位特别顾问。她和其他一群丧亲者
In other words, that gaslighting isn't just awful. It saps people's willingness to share their stories. But, Kristen is quick to point out, Democrats have thwarted the project too, albeit in a different key. Back in 2021, she flew to Washington, D.C. to meet with a special advisor to President Biden. She and a bunch of other bereaved people
和他坐在一张桌子旁，她谈到了政府需要做更多的工作来承认和纪念那些已经失去的生命。而他，我永远不会忘记他，有点像，我不会说愤慨，但有点像吸了一口气，只是说我们不能在与新冠作战的同时
were sitting around a table with him, and she talked about how the government needed to do more to acknowledge and commemorate the lives that had been lost. And he was, I will never forget him, sort of getting a little bit like, I wouldn't say indignant, but kind of like pulling in his breath a bit and just saying we cannot fight a war on COVID
纪念这场战争。当战争结束时，我们可以回来做那件事。克里斯汀经常从表面上的盟友那里听到这句话。现在还太早。她记录了拜登每次会见大楼倒塌、火灾或其他灾难的家庭的情况。她说，他从来没有与新冠丧亲者进行过这种专门的会面。在报道这篇文章时，我不得不定期等待我自己的愤怒浪潮过去。不得不为我们经历过的最大生命损失而战？
and remember the war at the same time. When the war is over, we can come out back and do that. Kristen hears that one a lot from ostensible allies. It's too early. She keeps a tally of every time Biden meets with families from a building collapse or a fire or other disaster. Never, she says, has he had this kind of dedicated meeting with the COVID bereaved. While reporting this piece, I periodically had to wait for my own waves of sputtering outrage to pass. Having to fight to remember the biggest loss of life we've ever experienced?
什么？但是，如果我诚实的话，我不得不怀疑有时我自己的动力有多少。越来越多地，我发现自己在做一种奇怪的新冠代码切换。一分钟，我会对政客们宣扬口罩强制令的邪恶感到震惊。下一分钟，我自己都不记得上次戴口罩是什么时候了。与“被新冠标记”的人交谈时，我意识到他们最大的障碍与其说是那些否认者和反疫苗者之类的。而是我们其余那些越来越不想再考虑它的人。
What? But, if I'm honest, I couldn't help wondering how much wind was in my own sales at times. More and more, I found myself doing a funny kind of COVID code switching. One minute, I'd be appalled by politicians proclaiming the evil of mask mandates. The next minute, I couldn't remember the last time I wore one myself. Talking to the marked by COVID folks, I realized their biggest hurdle isn't so much the deniers and the anti-vaxxers and whatnot. It's the rest of us who increasingly don't want to think about it at all.
我在民主党全国代表大会上发言后，我是每个人的好朋友。从2020年8月或2020年11月开始，支持我所说内容的人就慢慢减少了。因为人们想要继续前进。这种想要从震撼世界的疾病中继续前进的愿望并不完全是新冠所独有的。无论出于什么原因，大流行病位于我们蓄意健忘金字塔的最顶端。你上次看到1918年西班牙流感的纪念碑是什么时候？它杀死了5000万人。
After I spoke at the DNC, I was everybody's best friend. And since August of 2020 or November of 2020, it's been this slow decline of people supporting what I have to say. And because people want to move on. This desire to move on from world-shaking diseases isn't totally unique to COVID. For whatever reason, pandemics sit at the very top of our willful amnesia pyramid. When was the last time you saw a memorial to the Spanish flu of 1918? It killed 50 million people.
为此，我们得到了佛蒙特州巴里的一张小花岗岩长椅，由一对餐馆老板夫妇于2018年安装。所以我们纪念战争，我们纪念地震，我们纪念爆炸，我们纪念革命，对吧？但我们不纪念由于健康问题和大流行造成的巨大损失。那是玛丽安·赫希再次说道。所以这是一个担忧，就是我们之前看到的这种遗忘程度。但也总是有一种正常化、继续前进的冲动，我们制度的巨大失败正在被揭露，以及我们认为他们会想要掩盖它们，而不是真正解决为什么情况会变得如此糟糕，因为实际上它不必变得如此糟糕。
For this, we get a small granite bench in Barry, Vermont, installed by husband and wife restaurant owners in 2018. So we remember wars, we remember earthquakes, we remember bombings, we remember revolutions, right? But we do not remember massive loss due to health questions and pandemics. That's Mary and Hirsch again. So that was one concern was this level of forgetting that we saw before. But also the urge always to normalize, to move on, the tremendous failures of our institutions that were being revealed and how we thought they would want to cover them over and not really address why it got to be so bad, because it didn't actually have to be so bad.
团队一直在与华盛顿的官僚、世界上的杰伊·布洛克们以及公众的疲劳和惯性作斗争。他们考虑并放弃了各种纪念碑设计。但最终，他们确定了一个满足他们想要纪念碑所做的一切的设计。它承认了许多声音。它邀请参与。它涉及与Snapchat的合作。早在所有那些设计讨论中，克里斯汀的一位同学就向“被新冠标记”介绍了这家科技公司的人。当我听说他们最终达成合作时，我不会撒谎。我的心沉了一下。一家时髦的科技公司似乎离克里斯汀、克里斯汀、萨拉和其他人创造的那种家庭式叛乱氛围有百万英里远。但最重要的是，我的心很高兴他们走到了这一步。我为自己预订了一张
team had been battling DC bureaucrats, the J blocks of the world, and the general public's fatigue and inertia. They had considered and discarded various memorial designs. But finally, they'd settled on one that satisfied everything they wanted the memorial to do. It admitted many voices. It invited participation. And it involved a partnership with Snapchat. Way back in the midst of all those design discussions, a classmate of Kristen's had introduced Marked by COVID to folks at the tech company. When I heard they eventually hammered out a partnership, I'm not gonna lie. My heart sank a bit. A slick tech company seemed a million miles away from the home-spun insurgent vibe that Kristen and Christine and Sarah and the others had created. But mostly, my heart was happy they'd gotten this far. I booked myself a
去洛杉矶的机票，因为我终于要亲眼看看这座纪念碑了。我站在这个巨大的旧洛杉矶公墓入口外。在一些棕榈树下，有一块“被新冠标记”的人认领的人造草皮，就在非常嘈杂的圣莫尼卡大道旁边。我在这里参加一个原型的揭幕仪式，这是一个专注于在这里死于新冠的人的纪念碑。这是“被新冠标记”想要在全国各地建造的那种纪念碑，也是它最终想要放在国家广场上的那种纪念碑的较小版本。在接下来的一个小时里，该区域挤满了志愿者
ticket to LA because I was finally going to see this memorial for myself. I'm standing outside the entrance to this massive old LA cemetery. Under some palm trees, there's a patch of fake grass that the marked by COVID folks have claimed, right next to a very noisy Santa Monica Boulevard. I'm here for the unveiling of a prototype, a memorial focused on people who died from COVID here in LA. It's the kind of memorial that marked by COVID wants to build all around the country, and a smaller version of the kind it ultimately wants to sit on the National Mall. Over the next hour, the area fills with volunteers
买了去洛杉矶的机票，因为我终于要亲眼去看看这个纪念碑了。我站在洛杉矶这座巨大的老墓地入口外。在几棵棕榈树下，有一块人造草坪，那是“标记新冠”（marked by COVID）组织选定的地方，紧邻着非常嘈杂的圣莫尼卡大道。我来这里是为了参加一个原型的揭幕仪式，这是一个专门纪念在洛杉矶因新冠去世的人们的纪念碑。这是“标记新冠”组织希望在全国各地建立的那种纪念碑，也是他们最终希望在国家广场上建立的纪念碑的缩小版。在接下来的一个小时里，这个区域挤满了志愿者。
from the organization, curious onlookers, and mostly people who've lost someone to COVID. My husband and I used to read the newspaper in the morning together, and he was the only guy I knew that actually would laugh out loud at the comics. He won! He was a only guy I knew that actually would laugh out loud at the comics. He won! He was a great guy. That was Lucy Esparza-Casares. And this is Jennifer Torres-Kowalski. My daughter was Guinevere Juliane Artemis-Kowalski. She was born June 6, 2005. Guinevere played the clarinet and the viola and the French horn.
来自该组织、好奇的旁观者，以及大多数因新冠失去亲人的人。我和丈夫过去常在早上一起读报纸，他是唯一一个我认识的真正会对着漫画大声笑出来的人。他赢了！他是我认识的唯一一个真正会对着漫画大声笑出来的人。他赢了！他是个很棒的人。那是露西·埃斯帕扎-卡萨雷斯。这位是詹妮弗·托雷斯-科瓦尔斯基。我的女儿是吉尼维尔·朱莉安·阿耳忒弥斯-科瓦尔斯基。她出生于2005年6月6日。吉尼维尔会吹单簧管、拉中提琴和吹圆号。
She taught herself to crochet and would give away her creations to siblings and her friends. She was just deeply sweet. Her mom used to jokingly remind her that if a stranger pulled up in a van, she was not to get in. She was that trusting. One day, they thought she was having an asthma flare-up from smoke from nearby fires. It was COVID. One day they thought she was having an asthma flare up from smoke from nearby fires.
她自学了钩针编织，并把自己的作品送给兄弟姐妹和朋友。她非常甜美。她妈妈过去常开玩笑地提醒她，如果有陌生人开着货车停下来，千万不要上车。她就是那么容易相信别人。有一天，他们以为她是因为附近火灾的烟雾导致哮喘发作。其实是新冠。有一天他们以为她是因为附近火灾的烟雾导致哮喘发作。
It was COVID. Weeks later she was in a hospital bed aged 16. Luckily because she was a child we all got to be with her when we let her go so I got to crawl into bed with her for a final time and my dad was ten and daughter younger and older and I was 10 and daughter, younger and older. And they got to hold her hands, and we all got to be with her as she went. And it was just, it was really quick. We milled around like this for a while, and then everyone took seats in folding chairs arranged on the fake grass.
其实是新冠。几周后，16岁的她躺在病床上。幸运的是，因为她还是个孩子，我们都能在她离世时陪伴在她身边，所以我得以最后一次爬上床陪她，我爸爸当时十岁，女儿更小也更大，我当时10岁，女儿，更小也更大。他们得以握住她的手，我们都在她离去时陪伴着她。这真的，真的很快。我们像这样徘徊了一会儿，然后每个人都在摆在假草坪上的折叠椅上坐了下来。
Kristen Arquiza stepped up to a podium. I'm so excited to be here with you all today to be able to share with you a project that we've been working on since that day. The National COVID Memorial. Not the whole National COVID Memorial to be clear, but a prototype featuring some of those lost just in the LA area like Fiona who lost her mom early on in it and found Kristen on Facebook. She sent her a message saying,
克里斯汀·阿基扎走上讲台。我很高兴今天能和大家在这里分享一个我们从那天起就一直在做的项目。国家新冠纪念碑。明确地说，不是整个国家新冠纪念碑，而是一个原型，展示了仅在洛杉矶地区失去的一些人，比如菲奥娜，她在早期失去了母亲，并在Facebook上找到了克里斯汀。她发了一条信息说，
I don't know what is going on, but what you are doing is the only thing that makes sense. So after Fiona, there was then Carly. After Carly was Caitlin and Caitlin was Tara. And then Jeffrey and Lucy and countless other people who came forward to say, we cannot forget. Behind Kristen sat a round plinth, designed by the LA artist Marcos Letchens. Nothing was on it.
我不知道发生了什么，但你所做的是唯一有意义的事情。所以继菲奥娜之后，还有卡莉。继卡莉之后是凯特琳，凯特琳之后是塔拉。然后是杰弗里、露西和无数其他人站出来说，我们不能忘记。克里斯汀身后坐着一个圆形的基座，由洛杉矶艺术家马科斯·莱琴斯设计。上面什么都没有。
Just a big empty circle, shin high, and maybe 20 feet across. After she and others gave remarks, Chris and the other attendees started milling around again and pointing their phones at that plinth. To experience the memorial, I have to finally download Snapchat for the first time in my life. No, can't have my contacts, can't send me notifications. I find a special lens within the app marked by COVID. There it is. And then point my phone at the plinth.
只是一个巨大的空圆圈，小腿高，直径约20英尺。在她和其他人发表讲话后，克里斯和其他与会者又开始四处走动，并将手机对准那个基座。为了体验这个纪念碑，我不得不生平第一次下载Snapchat。不，不能获取我的联系人，不能给我发通知。我在应用程序中找到了一个由“Marked by COVID”标记的特殊镜头。就在那儿。然后我把手机对准基座。
Okay, I'm holding, oh, Jesus. I'm seeing hundreds of little tiny photographs swirling clockwise and upwards, like a DNA helix. And there's all these little rectangular photos just hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of them swirling up into the sky and I can touch one oh my god and it brings a photo an individual photo forward to me. Lord, I will never ever doubt Snapchat again. Using augmented reality, that's the same technology that paints the yellow first downline
好吧，我拿着，哦，天哪。我看到数百张小照片顺时针向上旋转，就像DNA螺旋一样。有所有这些小矩形照片，成百上千张，旋转着升向天空，我可以触摸其中一张，哦，天哪，它把一张照片，一张个人照片带到了我面前。天哪，我再也不会怀疑Snapchat了。使用增强现实技术，这和在电视转播的足球比赛中绘制黄色首攻线是同一项技术，
on a televised football game, marked by COVID has created an infinitely expandable, shockingly human take on memorialization. Oh, Jesus. Dr. Gay Griffin Snyder. We miss you. I hope you're keeping an eye on us and seeing these boys grow. It's hard to convey how beautiful this vortex of photos and obituaries is.
“Marked by COVID”创造了一种无限可扩展、令人震惊的人性化纪念方式。哦，天哪。盖伊·格里芬·斯奈德医生。我们想念你。我希望你在注视着我们，看着这些男孩成长。很难表达这张照片和讣告漩涡有多美。
I grew up in the Washington, D.C. area, surrounded by noble statues and somber slabs. So often, the actual humanity and the complexity and the heartbreak behind those memorials felt distant, bloodless, history bookish. The marked by COVID memorial is the opposite of that. Bo Yazzy. Bo was willing to help anyone in need.
我在华盛顿特区长大，周围环绕着高贵的雕像和阴沉的石板。通常，这些纪念碑背后真实的人性、复杂性和心碎感让人感到遥远、冷漠、像历史书一样。而“Marked by COVID”纪念碑则恰恰相反。博·亚齐。博乐于帮助任何有需要的人。
Loved his son very, very much. Using your phone to experience these remembrances isn't alienating as I'd feared. It's powerfully fitting, given how these devices were often the last point of contact for those who were losing someone. For so many, Kristen included, these impersonal gadgets, they were a lifeline when the hospital kept you out.
非常非常爱他的儿子。用手机来体验这些缅怀并不像我担心的那样疏远。这非常贴切，因为这些设备往往是那些失去亲人的人最后的联系点。对许多人来说，包括克里斯汀，这些冷冰冰的小玩意儿在医院把你拒之门外时，是救命稻草。
They were how you held hands. They were your desperate kiss goodbye. So it's weirdly touching that they're central to this memorial. And then you switch off the app and the whole thing vanishes. For the next hour, I watch people take in this prototype, absorb what it could mean on a national level. It is profound.
它们是你握住手的方式。它们是你绝望的告别之吻。所以，它们成为这个纪念碑的核心，这让人感到一种奇怪的触动。然后你关掉应用程序，整个东西就消失了。接下来的一个小时里，我看着人们体验这个原型，吸收它在国家层面上可能意味着什么。这意义深远。
At the same time, we are a relatively small group of random people near a car wash and an auto zone and a plumbing supply store gathered for something that most people just aren't thinking about. As they have from the beginning, the marked by COVID folks zoom every week with those in grief. They maintain an archive of any other COVID memorial they hear about, no matter how small or makeshift. And they're pitching states across the country, trying to get them interested in local memorials like the one Chris just saw in LA. But that permanent national COVID memorial remains their biggest challenge, not least
与此同时，我们是一群相对较小的随机人群，聚集在洗车店、汽车地带和管道供应店附近，为了大多数人根本没在想的事情。正如从一开始那样，Marked by COVID的人们每周都会与那些处于悲伤中的人进行视频会议。他们维护着一个他们听说的任何其他新冠纪念碑的档案，无论多么小或简陋。他们正在向全国各州推介，试图让他们对当地的纪念碑感兴趣，就像克里斯在洛杉矶看到的那样。但那个永久的国家新冠纪念碑仍然是他们最大的挑战，尤其是
because of all the stories of loss they still need to collect. We are on a quest to find everyone. Where it will live, when it will be done, nobody knows. But they press on. Because they have to. Because no one else anywhere understands the angles better or deeper. Over the year I spent with Marked by COVID, something became very clear to me.
因为他们还需要收集所有关于失去的故事。我们正在寻找每一个人。它将建在哪里，何时完成，没人知道。但他们坚持下去。因为他们必须这样做。因为没有其他人比他们更了解这些角度，更深地理解这些角度。在我和Marked by COVID相处的一年里，有些事情对我来说变得非常清楚。
Whether they're commemorating do-boys or pandemics, the makers of memorials possess a dark and penetrating wisdom. Maybe more than any of us, they understand the awful truth that no matter how colossally world-shaking some tragedy is, no matter how unforgettable, we will absolutely forget it. If something or someone doesn't stop us. with additional editing by Jason DeLeon. Mixed and sound designed by Martin Gonzalez. Music by Swan Real. Fact-checking by Graham Haysha. Special thanks this week to Marcus Letchens, Tara Krebs, Zach Zavala, Carly Greer, Fianna Tulip, DJ Arsene Versailles, and the rest of the Marked by COVID
无论是纪念多伊博伊还是大流行病，纪念碑的建造者都拥有黑暗而深刻的智慧。也许比我们任何人都更了解一个可怕的事实：无论某种悲剧多么震撼世界，无论多么令人难忘，我们绝对会忘记它。如果有什么人或事不阻止我们的话。由杰森·德莱昂进行额外编辑。由马丁·冈萨雷斯进行混音和声音设计。音乐由Swan Real创作。事实核查由格雷厄姆·海沙完成。本周特别感谢马库斯·莱琴斯、塔拉·克雷布斯、扎克·扎瓦拉、卡莉·格里尔、菲安娜·图利普、DJ阿尔塞纳·凡尔赛以及Marked by COVID的其他成员。
community. Kathy too is our executive producer at Colestate is our digital director. The rest of the team includes Chris Perube, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Lay, Laushamadhan, Joe Rosenberg, Gabriela Gladney, Kelly Prime, Jacob Maldonado-Medina, Sarah Bake, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of his logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Stitcher and Sirius XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building in beautiful uptown Oakland, California. If you haven't already done so, you should pick
凯西·图也是我们的执行制片人，科莱斯特是我们的数字总监。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·佩鲁贝、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、薇薇安·莱、劳沙马丹、乔·罗森伯格、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼、凯利·普莱姆、雅各布·马尔多纳多-梅迪纳、莎拉·贝克，以及我，罗曼·马斯。99%的标志是由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作的。我们是Stitcher和Sirius XM播客家族的一部分，现在总部位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的潘多拉大厦，向北六个街区。如果你还没有这样做，你应该买
up a copy of the Power Broker by Robert Caro and join our year long Power Broker book club. New episodes of the 99% of visible breakdown of the Power Broker hosted by me and Elliot Kaelin will drop monthly right here in this feed. It is so much fun. I hope you can join us. You can find us on all the usual social media, and we just started up a 99 PI discord server. Come join me and the rest of the staff to talk about the power broker, you know, what you've been reading, architecture, recommendations, books, podcasts, you're listening to anything as long as it is, you know,
一本罗伯特·卡罗的《权力掮客》，并加入我们为期一年的《权力掮客》读书俱乐部。由我和埃利奥特·凯林主持的99%可见的《权力掮客》解析新剧集将每月在这个订阅源中发布。这太有趣了。我希望你能加入我们。你可以在所有常见的社交媒体上找到我们，我们刚刚建立了一个99 PI Discord服务器。快来加入我和其他工作人员，谈谈《权力掮客》，你知道的，你读过的书、建筑、推荐、书籍、你正在听的播客，任何只要是，你知道的，
fun and nice. You can find a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
有趣且美好的东西。你可以在99PI.org找到该链接以及99PI过去的所有剧集。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。